Tony Stark should be in jail.
Yep. You heard me. I am totally serious.
When you go back and watch all the movies
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe, Tony Stark
breaks law after law after law just by being
Iron Man.
Don't believe me.
Well, I'm about to prove it to you.
Hello Internet!
Welcome to Film Theory, the show that wants
you to snap that subscribe button away.
You know, loyal theorists.
I’m not sure I've ever seen a franchise
go on such a rollercoaster of quality and
discourse as the Marvel Cinematic Universe
across the last three years.
Once held up as this beacon of real consistent
quality in an industry where blockbusters
were often garbage cash grabs, the quality
of the MCU has become mid at best.
Phase four had a lot of ups, sure, but it
also had a lot of really down, downs; confusing
and convoluted plots, baffling creative decisions,
cool ideas and character arcs that seemed
to be completely abandoned before we hit their
peak.
Honestly, after watching the “movie” that
was Ant-Man: Quantumania.
made go back and rewatch the older MCU films,
trying to identify where and what exactly
went wrong.
If you want to see what I think happened,
well, you can check out our video telling
Marvel that it's time to panic.
But as I was binging Iron Man yet again, something
else dawned on me.
Something that completely recontextualized
the MCU’s first and biggest hero.
Suddenly I realized that Tony Stark.
Yeah, he wasn't as heroic as I thought he
was.
This dude should be in prison multiple times
over.
Tony Stark was a serial womanizer, a liar
to everyone around him, and an arms dealer
responsible for potentially hundreds of thousands
of deaths before he ever had the idea of a
futuristic suit of armor.
He's hoarded world changing technology, like
the nanotech that powers the suit in Endgame
for himself and his friends.
And that's not even mentioning how he teams
up with the U.S. government to create the
Department of Damage Control, exploiting the
destruction that he himself causes with The
Avengers to further profit himself.
His actions led to the creation of villains
like the Iron Monger, Whiplash, the Vulture,
the fake Mandarin, Baron Zemo.
And do I even need to mention Ultron, who
killed thousands in Sokovia?
Tony Stark is a man who has a lot to answer
for.
Heck, even the Iron Man franchise itself agrees
with that statement.
So many of the franchise's stories are about
Tony a-tony-ing for his mistakes, and Tony
himself feels massive guilt for all of it
later in his life.
And all of this is awful, painting a picture
of a deeply flawed man in desperate need of
some therapy.
It doesn't hold a candle to the actual laws
that Tony breaks.
Seriously, as I was rewatching these movies,
I started to wonder how Tony Stark would fare
in the real world with our real world legal
system.
Superhero or no
throughout the MCU, the sins of Tony Stark
have added up.
Let me tell you, it wouldn't be looking good
for the invincible Iron Man if he did eventually
have his day in court.
That's right friendos, today we're tackling
a theorist classic: The good guy is bad, actually.
By the end of this, you'll never look at Iron
Man the same way again.
And the big twist, the thing that would have
really ruined Tony Stark, it boils down to
four tiny words:
I am Iron Man
Power up your arc reactor's loyal theorist.
Let's get into it.
So to begin, we're going to start with the
quote unquote, small laws that Tony breaks
throughout his career.
To start, let's look at Iron Man 3 and how
Stark's vendetta against the Mandarin probably
led him into multiple state and federal crimes,
especially that whole action set piece where
he breaks into the Mandarin's compound.
First of all, a lot of the improvised weapons
that he creates for this raid would have been illegal.
Specifically, I'm thinking about all those
explosives that he creates from everyday supplies
that he bought at Home Depot.
It's a federal crime to possess any unregistered
explosive devices which could carry a maximum
federal penalty of ten years in prison.
Why count these and not the missiles in the
Iron Man suit?
Well, he, as a defense contractor, likely
did register those explosives, but all the
little bombs from Iron Man 3, those were made
under the radar, and he definitely didn't
have time to file the paperwork there.
Additionally, when Tony steals one of the
guard's guns and then threatens Trevor and
the groupies with it, that would have counted
as multiple crimes.
Just pointing a gun at someone is considered
aggravated assault and it can result in five
years in prison and five years probation.
But possession of an illegal gun in Florida.
And he definitely had that gun illegally,
Tony just straight up stole It.
Could mean that he's facing another $10,000
in fines and 15 years in prison.
But honestly, Stark jumping the fence to confront
the Mandarin here in the first place likely
would have been its own crime.
Normally, I'd call this breaking and entering,
but this part of the movie actually takes
place in Miami, Florida, and that state doesn't
consider breaking and entering its own crime.
Instead, this would have been classified as
something more severe: first degree burglary,
because Tony illegally entered a building
with the intent to commit a criminal offense.
He then assaulted someone while inside there
and then likely caused more than $1,000 in
property damage with those explosive Christmas
ornaments.
In short, this would be up to $10,000 in fines
and 30 years in prison.
So things are already legally shaky for ol’
Tony Stark.
But all of that is in pursuit of a known criminal,
an international terrorist.
Is there anything else more serious that we
can pin on Tony?
Absolutely.
Look, no further than The Avengers, which
sees Tony off alone hacking government computers
to get information he wasn't supposed to have.
First of all, trespassing on federal government
property without expressed permission can
be a serious offense.
I see this going one or two ways.
The Helicarrier could be considered a military
base, in which case Tony would be subject
to six months in jail and or a $500 fine.
Or it would be akin to trespassing in a federal
building similar to the U.S. Capitol, which
would be a misdemeanor punishable by six months
in prison or a $5,000 fine.
Also, depending on how important the government
deems a high ranking military official like
Nick Fury, Tony could be in a lot more trouble.
In that case, this trespassing would become
a Class E felony, and he'd be behind bars
for up to five years and or a $250,000 fine.
But even worse than all of that would be Tony's
hacking of military computers on the Helicarrier.
This would be a textbook violation of the
Computer Fraud and Abuse Act, which makes
it a federal crime to gain unauthorized access
to protected government computers.
In fact, it makes it illegal to even attempt
or conspire to do that hacking.
If charged with the crime, Tony would be facing
up to a year in federal prison if this is
deemed a lesser offense.
But in all likelihood, he'd probably be charged
for a serious offense and given 10 to 20 years.
Since the hacking involves some very sensitive
national security information.
Y’know what else?
let’s actually double this, as we also see
Tony hacking into a national security contractors
database in Iron Man 3 and Captain America
Civil War, where he hacks the Rafts’ microphones
and cameras.
I mean, my man can't go more than a movie
or two without breaking into secure government computers.
But in The Avengers, Tony was doing his best
to defend New York and all of Earth from Loki.
a few cybercrimes here and sneaking around
there is justifiable, right?
Maybe.
But you know, it's a lot harder to justify?
how much he endangers Peter Parker.
By giving Peter the Stark built Spidey equipment
and then encouraging him to go out crime fighting
to the point that Peter literally died out
in space.
Tony definitely broke a few laws there.
Now, surprisingly, I wasn't able to find anything
specific about being the cause of death for
a minor out in space at the hands of a giant
purple raisin man.
No laws currently on the books about that
one, I'm afraid.
But it is a crime in New York to endanger
the welfare of anyone who's 16 years of age
and younger.
Between Civil War, Spider-Man Homecoming and
Infinity War.
Peter's around 14 to 16 years old, so he definitely
qualifies here.
And Tony bringing him into the world of crime
fighting, giving him equipment and encouraging
vigilante justice, that right there definitely
qualifies.
Even if he is telling Peter that he needs
to be better and safer, this is still a Class
A misdemeanor, punishable by up to a year
in jail.
It's also just a really bad look for Tony
to be honest.
Another really bad look, pretty much everything
that Tony does with Peter in Civil War.
First off, he takes custody of a child under
false pretenses and definitely takes them
across international borders illegally.
According to the U.S. Department of Homeland
Security, Customs and Border Protection.
While minors can travel internationally without
a parent or legal guardian.
Many destinations require notarized, written
consent from their parents.
Given that she didn't even know that Peter
was Spider-Man, Aunt May definitely did not
give her consent for Peter to go get beat
up by Captain America in a German airport.
And even if she did, Peter doesn't have the
paperwork necessary for the trip.
And this would be a serious crime for Tony.
In fact, it would probably have been defined
as human trafficking, though that term is
most often connected with very dark, real
world tragedies.
According to the DHS, human trafficking can
also include the use of fraud or coercion
to obtain labor, and traffickers might use
manipulation or false promises of well-paying
jobs to lure victims in.
Ha, a Stark Industries internship, a position
in The Avengers, that sure sounds like manipulation
to get Spidey overseas.
All while putting him in the sights of trained
soldiers, thieves, sorcerers and assassins.
In a fight that left someone outright paralyzed
for life.
Yeah, that's really not good there, Tony.
Human trafficking is a federal crime with
a punishment that can include anywhere between
20 years and life in prison.
Even after Tony dies to save the universe
from Thanos, he's still performing Legally
shady acts with Peter, specifically leaving
him the Edith glasses.
Just in case you don't remember, these give
Peter control over Stark's defense satellite
system as well as some super dangerous drones.
It is wild.
Now, it's obviously difficult to find a 1
to 1 case in the real world, since we don't
have armies of killer drones controlled by
AI glasses.
So we're going to use similar laws for guns
instead.
In the United States, you are allowed to leave
your weapons to an heir after you die.
But all guns bequeathed in this way are subject
to the National Firearms Act of 1932, as well
as the revised version of the Gun Control
Act of 1968.
According to these laws, you have to register
certain heavy duty weapons with the government
before you can leave them to an heir.
Additionally, the NFA also requires that the
permanent transport of NFA firearms across
state lines be reported.
Peter didn't even know the glasses controlled
these killer drones until after he left the
U.S. so they'd be labeled as contraband in
the eyes of the United States.
They legally could not have been passed to
an heir and should have instead been considered
abandoned by Stark after his death and handed
over to the Bureau of Alcohol, Tobacco, Firearms
and Explosives.
And that's not even me mentioning that the
sort of automatic weaponry used in the drones
are just straight up illegal in the European
Union countries that they're visiting in Far
From Home.
To be fair, Tony was dead at this point and
wouldn't have seen justice for his crime.
But still, this is another no-no that Tony
definitely did-did.
And while the Edith drones were certainly
sketchy, the Iron Man suits themselves likely
would also be illegal too.
Guns aren't the only thing that can be counted
as regulated weapons.
The suits would absolutely be something that
the government would likely want some oversight on.
I mean, sure, these things might be humanoid
shaped and called suits.
But they certainly have more in common with
an Abrams tank than an Armani suit.
Believe it or not, but there are actually
regulations in the U.S. about whether or not
you can own an operational tank.
Because tanks have weapons with bores or barrels
that are wider than three quarters of an inch.
The National Firearms Act classifies them
as destructive weapons, though Tony suits
mostly use replacer or energy weapons.
Which, side note, we should probably do a
theory about that at some point, right?
Like what are replacers?
Are they real?
And if they are, are they legal?
Either way, repulsive weapons would absolutely
fit that same destructive weapon category.
As such, Tony would have to get a permit to
even own his Iron Man suits, which really
doubt that the government would want to give
him, at least at first.
Remember he’s basically a rogue agent throughout
Iron Man 1, And the government outright wants
to confiscate all his technology in Iron Man
2.
And any violation of the National Firearms
Act is a felony, punishable by a fine of up
to $250,000 and up to ten years in prison.
And on top of being considered something equivalent
to a tank, the Iron Man suits would also likely
be considered personal aircraft.
Since the Federal Aviation Administration
considers any craft weighing more than 254
lb and flying faster than 63 miles per hour
as an ultralight aircraft.
Legally speaking, all of the Iron Man suits
might have to be registered as small, private
airplanes.
And if that's the case, the fact that Tony's
flying them through populated urban areas,
cities like New York, that is absolutely unacceptable.
Even Stark entering space like we see in Infinity
War would likely be against the law.
Since you actively need permits from a spacefaring
nation to enter the atmosphere within their
airspace, all of this would cause the FAA
to fine Tony another $50000 to $400000 per violation.
Even if Tony was somehow able to clear all
of these hurdles, file all the correct paperwork,
and get approved for all the Iron Man-ing
we see throughout the franchise, we know that
there are still times that he's operated his
suits criminally.
During Tony's lowest point in Iron Man 2,
when he thinks that he's dying and throws
a party in his depression, he wears the suit
while clearly under the influence of alcohol.
Now, this is really bad, and since we've deduced
that the suit's likely count as some sort
of vehicle, this would be the equivalent of
operating a dangerous vehicle while under
the influence.
This scene takes place in Tony's house in
Malibu.
And if we're specifically talking about planes,
which remember the Iron Man suits would qualify
as, flying while under the influence in California
carries a mandatory 30 day to six month jail
sentence, up to 15 years in prison and up
to $250,000 in fines.
Additionally, Tony accidentally and then intentionally
discharges his weapons while at the party.
Did it see how close he came to hitting those
innocent people just there to have a good time?
This would absolutely count as negligent discharge
of a firearm and could either be counted as
a misdemeanor or a felony.
It also carries a sentence of up to three
years in jail.
So that's a massive laundry list of crimes
that Tony's committed over the years under
the guise of helping people.
Just for my count here, he'd be facing upwards
of 174 years in prison and fines in excess
of $1,171,000.
And that's just from the few things that I
brought up here that we see in the movies.
Now the money?
Yeah, we all recognize that that doesn't matter,
he's a billionaire, it’s a drop in the bucket
for him.
As for whether or not he'd actually spend
that time in prison?
Well, he probably should.
But the American legal system can be an imperfect
place, especially when you're talking about
high profile, wealthy individuals.
So, is that it?
After everything that we've listed out here
today: between assault, hacking, endangering
a minor, operating the legal equivalent of
a flying tank while under the influence, would
all of this just be a mild inconvenience for
Tony Stark?
a legal bump in the road that he can make
go away by paying his fines and winning the
jury to his side?
No loyal theorist, Tony, makes one final massive
mistake that would have ruined his life or
at least destroyed his career as Iron Man.
And it's right here.
This iconic moment that basically started
the biggest movie franchise in history would
have absolutely stopped Tony Stark in his
tracks. Why?
Because the government would now know that
he is, in fact, Iron Man.
See, some of the laws that Tony breaks throughout
his run in the MCU have other punishments
beyond just fines and jail time.
For example, any violation of the National
Firearms Act means that the weapon involved
is forfeit and can be confiscated by the government.
So just owning one of these operational Iron
Man suits without a permit from the US government
would likely mean that the government could
take the suits and Tony would have no legal recourse.
But the craziest thing they wouldn't actually
need any hard evidence that Tony had broken
any laws.
Civil forfeiture is a process where law enforcement
can seize the assets of a person suspected
of a crime without actually charging them.
And if Tony were to successfully fight that
in court and get his armor back, well, then
the government could play an UNO reverse card
and use eminent domain, which allows them
to pay Stark what they consider to be a fair
amount for the armor and still take it without
his consent.
And if you think they wouldn't do this, it's
not like Tony's in good graces of the U.S.
federal government for a lot of his run as
hero.
We actually see the U.S. government acting
on at least one of these inside the movies.
In Iron Man 2, the Senate is holding hearings
about whether or not Stark should hand over
the Iron Man weapon for the good of the U.S..
And as soon as Tony starts acting irresponsible
in public, Rhodey takes one of the suits on
behalf of the U.S. military.
Probably using exactly one of these laws.
None of this would have been possible if the
government had no proof, no leads, that Tony
Stark was Iron Man.
And what did Tony do?
He confessed.
Not only to owning the equivalent of a flying
tank, bragging about it in front of Congress
on international TV, but also to every crime
committed while using the suits.
Tony Stark in his hubris, ruined himself with
those four little iconic words, because if
the government didn't know he was Iron Man,
well, they couldn't charge him with any Iron
Man crimes.
Just looking at this laundry list, Tony's
life is so comically over the top illegal
that there has to be some explanation for
how he isn't rotting behind bars.
Maybe, just maybe, all the favors that he
makes for the government later on in the franchise:
Keeping War Machine up to date, signing the
Sokovia Accords, helping them found a department
of damage control.
Maybe that's him performing some community
service for the government to avoid jail time.
But I suppose that's a theory for another
day.
And as always, my friends remember, it's all
just a theory A FILM THEORY!
aaaaaaaand cut.